how can landscapes imbue memory right
when we think about this notion implore
bus unum out of many one it's pretty
screens concept right I mean with all
different races and cultures of people
how do you boil it down to one thing
I want to share with you today this idea
of the pluribus unum and how our
landscape might imbue those memories of
diverse perspectives as well as force us
to stop trying to narrow things down to
a single clean set of identities as an
educator designer I'd like to share with
you five simple concepts that I've
developed through my work and I'd like
to share with you five projects where we
can begin to see how the memory around
us where things have happened can
actually force us to look at one another
in a different way and lastly this is
not just an American motto anymore I
think he floor of us Unum is global
we're in this thing together first great
things happen when we exist in each
other's world like today right the world
of community gardens most of you have
probably seen a community garden they're
all about subsistence and food right
I'll tell you a little story what
happened in New York more than a decade
ago they tried to sell all their
community gardens and Bette Midler
developed a non-profit the New York
restoration project they literally
brought all the gardens and decided to
save them and then they had another
novel idea let's bring in world-class
designers and let them go out into
communities and make these beautiful
gardens and maybe they might not just be
about food and so they called me and I
designed one in Jamaica Queens and on
the way to design in this garden I went
to the New York restoration project
office
and I noticed a familiar name on the
door downstairs I go upstairs and I said
you guys know who's downstairs and they
said gun it
I said gun it you mean g-unit Kurtis 50
cent Jackson and they said yeah and I
said yes and so we went downstairs and
before you knew it
Kurtis Beth and the rest of them form
this collaboration and they built this
garden in Jamaica Queens and it turned
out Curtis 50-cent grew up in Jamaica
and so again when you start bringing
these worlds together
me Curtis bet you get something more
incredible you get a garden that last
year was voted one of the top ten secret
gardens in New York right it's for young
and old but more importantly it's a
place it was a story at times about six
months ago where this young woman found
solace in going to the garden had
nothing to do with me it had more to do
with 50 I'm sure but it has inspired
people to think about gardens and
sharing each other's worlds in a
different way next concept Tunis it's
not as simple as I thought it would be
to explain but as I left to go to
college my father looked at me and said
Junior you're gonna have to be both
black and white when you go out there
and if you go back to the early parts of
the 20th century w/e be DuBose famous
activists said it's this peculiar
sensation that the Negro has to walk
around being viewed through the lens of
other people and this Tunis this
double-consciousness right and I want to
argue that more than a hundred years
later that Tunis has made a strong and
resilient and I would say for brown
people women all of us who have to
navigate the world through the eyes of
others we should now share that strength
to the rest of those who had the
privilege to be singular I'd like to
share with you a project because I do
think this Tunis can find it
self in the world around us and it's
beginning to happen where we beginning
to share these stories at the University
of Virginia the Academical village by
Thomas Jefferson it's a place that we're
getting to notice now was built by
African hands so we have to begin to say
okay how do we talk about that as the
university was expanding to the south
they found a site that was the house of
Kitty foster free African woman African
American woman and she was there and her
descendants they all sort of lived there
and she cleaned for the boys of a UVA
but as they found the archaeology they
asked me if I would do a commemorative
piece so the tunis of this landscape
both black and white I decided to do a
piece based on shadows and light and
through that we were able to develop a
shadow catcher that would talk about
this Tunis in a different way so when
the light came down there would be this
ride to heaven when there's no light
it's silent and in the landscape of
Thomas Jefferson it's a strange thing
it looked doesn't it's not made of brick
it's a strange thing and it allows these
two things to be unresolved and we don't
have to resolve these things I want to
live in a world where the resolution
there's an ambiguity between things
because that ambiguity allows us to have
a conversation when things are clear and
defined we forget the next example
empathy and I've heard that a couple of
times in this conference but this notion
of caring right 25 years ago when I was
a young pup very optimistic we wanted to
design a park in downtown Oakland
California for the homeless people and
we said homeless people can be in the
same space as people who wear suits and
everyone's like that's never got our
work people are not gonna eat lunch with
the homeless people we built the park
cost 1.1 million dollars we wanted a
bathroom we wanted horseshoes barbecue
pits
smokers picnic tables shelter and all of
that we had to design we went to the
then mayor said mr. mayor it's only
gonna cost you 1.1 million dollars and
he looked at me for homeless people and
he didn't give us the money so he walked
out unfettered and we raised the money
Clorox gave us money
the National Park Service built the
bathroom so we were able to go ahead
because we had empathy now 25 years
later right we have a even a larger
homeless problem in the Bay Area but the
park is still there and the people are
still there so for me that's a success
and when people see that hopefully
they'll have empathy for the people
under freeways in tents and why can't
our public spaces house them and force
us to be empathetic and the image on the
left is Lafayette Square Park today the
image on the right
this 1906 Golden Gate Park after the
earthquake why do we have to have
cataclysmic events to be empathetic our
fellow men are out there starving women
sleeping on the street and we don't see
them put them in those spaces and
they'll be visible
and to show you that there are still
people out there with empathy the
Oakland Raiders Bruce Irvin fries fish
every Friday afternoon for anyone who
wants it and by going to that park that
Park became the vehicle for him
traditional belongs to all of us and
this is a simple one you go into some
neighborhoods beautiful architecture
beautiful parks but if people look a
different way it's not traditional it's
not until they leave and then new people
come in where the traditional gets
valued a little quick story here 1888
Opera House the oldest in San Francisco
sits in Bayview Hunters Point over its
history its provided theatre places for
businesses places for community
gatherings etc it's also a place where
Ruth Williams taught many black actors
think Danny Glover came from this place
but over time with our 1980s federal
practices a lot of these community
institutions fell into disrepair with
the San Francisco Arts Council we were
able to raise money and to actually
refurbish the place and we were able to
have a community meeting and within the
community meeting people got up and said
this place feels like a plantation why
are we locked in why can't we learn
theatre and over the years people had
start putting in chicken coops hay bales
community gardens and all these things
and they could not see that traditional
thing behind them but we said we're
bringing the community back American
Disability Act we were able to get five
million dollars and now the tradition
belongs to these brown people is running
black people and they use it and they
learn theatre after-school programs
there's no more chickens right but there
is art and lastly I want to share with
you a project that we're currently
working on and I think it will force us
all to remember in a really different
way there are lots of things in the
landscape around us and most of time we
don't know what's below the ground here
in Charleston South Carolina
a verdict piece of grass most people
just pass by a daily but underneath it
it's where they discovered Ghats dunes
Wharf we think more than 40% of the
African Diaspora landed here right how
could you forget that right how could
you forget so we dug dug and we found
the wharf and so in 2020 Harry Cobb and
myself and others are building the
International African American Museum
and it will celebrate this place where
we know beneath the ground thousands
died perish the food chain of the bay
changed sharks came closer to the bay
it's where slaves were stored right I
mean imagine this hallowed ground so
when this new design the ground will
erupt and it will talk about this
tension that sits below the columns and
the ground is made of tabby shales
scooped up from the Atlantic a reminder
of that awful crossing and as you make
your way through on the other side
you're forced to walk through the
remains of the warehouse where slaves
were stored hot sultry days for days and
perished and you'll have to come face to
face with the Negro who worked in the
marshes who was able to sort of not with
the sickle cell trait able to stand in
high waters for long long days and at
night it'll be open 24/7 for everybody
to experience but we'll also talk about
those other beautiful things that my
African ancestors brought with them a
love of landscape a respect for the
spirits that live in trees and rocks and
water but the ethnobotanical aspects the
plants that we use from a disabled
purposes but more importantly we want to
remind people in Charleston South
Carolina of the black bodies that's when
you go to Charleston today
the Confederacy is celebrated probably
more than any other city and you don't
have a sense of blackness at all the
Brooks map which was an image that
helped abolitionists sort of see and be
merciful for that condition of the
crossing is something that we want to
repeat and I was taken by the conceptual
'ti of this kind of digital print that
sits in the museum in Charleston so we
decided to bring the water up on top of
the surface seven feet above tide and
then cast the figures full length six
feet multiply them across the surface in
tabby and then allow people to walk
across that divide and hopefully as
people come the water will drain out
fill up drain out and fill up and you'll
be forced to come to terms right with
that memory of place that memory of that
crossing that at times seems very lucid
and clear but at other times forces us
again to reconcile the scale and
hopefully as people move through this
landscape every day unreconciled they'll
remember and hopefully when we remember
the pluribus unum thank you
[Applause]